I think the dark nights racist will
always be remembered as a film that just
couldn't quite step out of the shadow of
its predecessor.
The dark nights,
and I think we all know who's
responsible for this.
Good evening,
ladies and gentle man.
We are tonight's entertainment.
However,
we can see the dark nights rises on its
own not only as a good,
if not excellent film births as a
closure of the trilogy that's perfectly
built upon and resource the inner
struggle of Batman that has been built
up within the previous films.
To do this,
however,
we must first reject to political
readings of the film that dominated for
fuse and discussions on the dark knight
rises.
We do this by first exploring the ways
in which Christopher Nolan constructs
narratives and then showing the
underlying psychological symbolism to
which the personal story of the dark
knight that's rices escape.
There
now in many refuse and discussions of
the dark knight rises the supposed
political meaning of the film.
What's a central topic I have discussed
before,
how in Juneau,
many reviewers and pundits mistakenly
focused on Juno supposed political
message considering abortion and
motherhood's a similar fate has befallen
the dark knight rises Cosworth the
reviewers and pundits clave that the
dark knight rises also clear and it's
important conservative message.
According to them,
the dark knight rises shows perfectly.
The evil of leftist political revolution
is beans for Toric,
not the same as that of a Marxist
revolutionary leader or even closer to
home as death of the occupy Wall Street
movement.
Take Gotham from dark car rock.
Those are generations who have kept you
down with myths of I'll put shoes on a
team and we give it back to you.
The people.
Roundup is yours.
A sentencing trials.
Now,
the spires by the trials of the French
Revolution as conservative pundits,
Ben Shapiro states,
dark knight rises was probably not even
meant to be a conservative movie.
The entire movie is a diatribe about
Marxism and the French revolution.
I mean,
there's including a full trial,
seen a mock trial team.
Uh,
it's,
it's fantastic.
Even more so.
It is the police as representatives of
order and establishment,
the together with,
well for Fuck Sake,
a billionaire defend the city against
this Marxist revolution of the people
and who are higher of the ferry left
progressive websites alone,
even dare to call the Dark Knight
Advices,
a fascist movie stating the Mesas are
the Philippines and the one time
overlords are the heroes.
Although some conservatives to celebrate
Christopher Nolan as much need as
conservative voice in Liberal Hollywood.
He himself was surprised by these
political interpretations of his film.
He stated what was surprising to me is
how many pundits booth right about the
political interpretation of the film and
not understand that any one political
interpretation necessarily involve
ignoring huge chunks of the film.
Nolan argued death.
He simply tried to expose tensions in
society that somebody could exploit and
that you can get falsely different
political interpretations from the
movie.
Slash Boise Sec,
for example,
stated that there is very much a strange
attraction and excitement in the film
considering the idea of power to the
people.
He can see this for example in catwoman
who so seductively whispers to our
billionaire protagonist.
You think all this can last storm coming
story when your friends better because
you're all kind of wonder how you ever
and leave.
So
and the strange satisfaction we gets
when Bain states who his employer,
this gives you,
Jesus concludes that the interpretation
of the dark knight rises as conservative
or Liberal,
I have fewer sands for fewer assess more
about them than about the film itself.
Now I think by focusing so much on the
political meaning of the film,
we are not only missing the two team of
the film,
but we are also fundamentally missing
how Christopher Nolan Constructs his
narratives.
The epidermis,
the film supposed to conservative
message can be seen in the final clash
of the good guy police protectors of law
and order to get her with Batman versus
the Marxists proletariats less by bane
totally doors.
But then it turns out that the true
pivotal scene of the film is the one
that comes right off to this clash where
it is revealed that a real villain and
leader of the League of shadows is
affect Miranda,
Datto Frosto,
ghoul
child Razia alcohol may decline.
Then he's not the
I
and the lime not ordinary.
Such a plot twist is of course typical
for Christopher Nolan.
Famous force layered complicated
narratives where nothing is but it
seems.
Now,
Walter Ben Michael's has analyzed
Nolan's narrative style and concluded
that the key to notice plot twist is
they're building towards the twist.
The information to see the twist coming
is already there.
Never show anyone,
beg you,
and they'll fly you for the secret,
but as soon as you give it up,
you'll be nothing to
he states for known as plot twists to be
successful,
the audience must deceive itself.
Must refuse to see the obvious
explanation for what is in front of it's
very eyes.
Nolan manipulates the audience desire to
be mystified by what they see.
So deathly effect when the hidden
information is finally revealed,
it's magnified indeed normalness called
filmic narrative itself.
The controlled release of information,
Nolan often heights,
the information in elaborate layers of
narratives search as we can see in films
like the Prestige Memento and inception.
Now the narrative structure of the dark
knight trilogy is more straight forward
than that of these fills,
but Nolan's plot twists and hidden
information is still there.
By rewatching the dark knight rises with
the plot twist in mind,
we can see that the film central team
isn't a straight forward action hero
clash off button and for us has been
both a completion of betterment's own
psychological struggle in the dark
knight rises.
We meet Bruce Wayne,
not only in a horrible physical state,
but also in a horrible psychological
state.
Still wallowing in the debt off Rachel
and by extension his parents,
he cannot leave Gotham and the Batman
behind.
I did find so I know and you lost him,
but that's all part of living sir,
but you're not living.
You're just waiting,
hoping,
but things to go bad.
Again.
Nolan himself has set that gotten itself
is a symbol for Bruce Wayne's
psychological state.
We can also find bruce ways,
psychological struggle in the symbolic
objects of his mother's necklace.
That's a beautiful necklace.
Reminds me of one that belonged to my
mother.
Can't be the same
cause.
Her pearls are in this safe,
which is broken.
Rushees shut in Batman begins,
but now it's reassembled by bruce and
kept in a safe before it got stolen by
Serena Ak Catwoman.
This necklace in the film contains a
whole array off symbolic gesturing.
We can see it in Bruce repairing the
necklace,
which is symbolic for trying to heal his
wounds to keeping it in a safe as
symbolic for trying to protect his
wounded psych.
This use of a safe as a symbol to
protect one psych is of course also seen
and one of nowness other films inception
to bruce keeping us modest necklace.
We can see that he can't let go of the
past and a distress.
Not a coincidence that the woman who
takes the necklace away from it.
It's also the woman who eventually is
critical for Bruce being able to let go
of this past.
Come with me.
Save
yourself.
You don't owe these people anymore.
You've given them everything.
Now,
upon second viewing,
we know that the true feeling of the
film is Miranda and she is very much
parallel to Bruce Wayne's story,
but Bruce Wayne and Batman begins
Wallace for French,
for a spouse.
Death almost joined the League of
shadows.
Bird thank creates Batman.
We run that.
I had a similar faith where her mother
was killed by criminals as a father by
Bruce Wayne.
Yes,
she does.
Joined the League of shadows.
Rick,
in this video on the joker,
lessons from the screenplay explains the
joker is an amazing antagonist because
he exploits the weaknesses of the
protagonists,
Batman and that they both Bethel for the
soft Gotham in the dark.
Knight rises.
This is build upon.
We know that Beth man lost better for
Gotham sold because it's Yoka turned
hockey dance and that's a piece in
Godson is built upon the lie,
which Miranda through Bain exposes in
the dark nights,
Bruce Chooses Rachel A.
Ball off.
Harvey Dent who represents hopeful
Gotham,
but she's still dice.
All right.
Listen some
me,
Rhonda as a villain,
dust users,
bruises,
weakest points,
his loneliness,
his heartbreak,
and his desire to love a woman.
Now,
Miranda,
his true identity is of course carefully
hidden and therefore the central team of
bruises,
psychological battle is as well.
Yes,
upon rewatching the film,
the information is always there.
Offer plays an interesting role in this
by stating his hope that bruce will
leave,
gotten Beth and his boss behaves to find
happiness.
He creates focus on the two central team
of Boucher.
Psychological journey.
I'll never one need you to come back to
Gotham.
I waste no,
there was nothing here for you.
Pain and tragedy and I wanted something
more for you to know.
Yeah.
It's by explaining pain as a dangerous
villain to bruce offered helps tricking.
The fewer into not seeing the two
villain is Miranda
who's a member of the League of shadows
and then he was actually indicating any
man who is too extreme.
The ratio.
There's not that the,
I didn't realize I was known for
trifling criminals.
That was Zane and you could just strap
up your leg and put your mask back on.
Oh,
Fred is the moral center of the trilogy,
the Voice of Wisdom.
And especially when in the dark nights
he so beautifully explained,
well it makes a joker tick.
Some men just want to wash the world,
but when he explains why Bain is so
dangerous,
we fully believe him.
Even when we see Miranda suggests a fee
using mosques.
Ethan when the camera focuses on the
scar on her back there,
she got from the League of shadows and
Ethan will be clear to see that the
child or the escapes is a girl that even
some of looks like Miranda and doesn't
have to suppose scars,
Death Bain receives in the pit because
we believe all threats.
We do not see it.
Yeah.
To information is there.
The thematic resolution of the dark
knight rises isn't Batman Wins.
Spain loses this conservatism wins
occupy losers because Bain isn't the
coal antagonist of the film and if you
don't see this,
then we also missed the importance of
the second twist of the film where we
find out that that man is not death
birth,
indeed the life and that he did truly
leave behind the Batman,
Gotham and bane of his past.
The dark knight rises is not about a
fiscally broken Beth man that rises out
of the pit through defeat Bain.
It's about Bruce Wayne who rises out of
his psychological pain to leave the
death of his parents.
Rachel,
the city of Carson and his persona as
Batman truly behind.
Thank you all so much for watching.
So first of all,
thanks to scholar Benjamin and winter
halter,
whose paper,
while some main inspiration for this
video and also two lessons from the
screenplay who gave me the ID to explore
the last installment of the Dark Knight
Trilogy.
Further,
it's going to be the joker,
but there are certainly an important
deeper theme in the last film death
closest Bruce's journey.
Follow us on facebook and twitter.
And if you want access to more for work,
you can support us on Patrion tomorrow
for patrons.
I will do another video where I talked
loosely about the film as my essay.
I will,
for example,
explore other symbolic gestures and
explain why so many pundits and
reviewers didn't see the underlying
central team,
but instead focused on the supposed
political arc of better than the first
has been for everyone else.
See you next time.